bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ron boyd
qui s'oppose donc aux élections
législatives alors qu'une partie de
l'opposition assuré ses partisans
d'efficacité de la transparence de ces
élections
pour quelles raisons ci au post il
bonsoir
j'écoute et je crois qu'il a toujours
plaidé au fond cette idée que le le
processus électoral à me dénigrer lien
n'était pas régulier selon lui en
réalité le les élections qui ont lieu
dimanche
la s'inscrivent dans la tradition je
dirais constitutionnel c'est-à-dire que
quand mémoire l'élection a eu lieu en
2015 décembre 2015 qui avait été
remportée par l'opposition vénézuélienne
qui ensuite a été tout de suite acceptée
par nicolas maduro
il se trouve qu'il ya eu un contentieux
si vous voulez par rapport à quatre
députés qui avaient été invalidées et
c'est à partir de là qu'il ya une crise
à la fois institutionnelle politique y
compris à l'international qui se
prolonge avec entre temps une élection
de bagoro en 2018 et qui actuellement se
poursuit par le fait que les élections
qui arrivent dimanche d'abord fait
l'objet d'un consensus d'une partie
simplement de l'opposition vénézuélienne
rappelons quand même qu'il ya 107 partis
politiques qui se présente à l'élection
au dimanche la 14 mille candidats il ya
eu trois grands débats électoraux dans
le pays mais il ya toujours eu une
frange de l'opposition radicale qui a
été soutenu et financé par les etats
unis et en particulier l'administration
bush
les kids explique cette situation de
blocage qui se situer au niveau
international monsieur wade au fait
campagne auprès du sénat français
sachez que la commission qui les réunit
utilisa il a reçu tout à l'heure recevra
aussi l'ambassadeur du venezuela en
france pour avoir un point de vue
éclairé et je dirais équilibré mais ce
ne sont pas les sénateurs français
qu'ils votent dimanche prochain au
venezuela s'était même ma question
pardonnez-moi ses fans à vitry parce que
on se demande pourquoi le sénat français
c'est vrai que quand on est moins
experts que vous ayez beaucoup de
personnes qui le sont moins vous bien
évidemment sur ce sujet on peut se
demander que fait juan guido au sénat
français écoutez c'est la liberté des
parlementaires de recevoir et
d'auditionner ce qu'il souhaite entendre
c'est une position qui effectivement a
rejoint certaines certaines positions
diplomatiques mais qui ne reflètent pas
en tout cas la réalité du terrain
électoral au venezuela le que le sénat
veuille recevoir et auditionné qu'ils
entendent c'est son affaire
ce qui est important c'est qu'il y ait
d'autres points de vue que pour que les
sénateurs soit éclairé en bonne en bonne
connaissance de gauche
je précise que le système électoral
vénézuélien et gérer à la fois par
commission nationale électorale qui est
indépendante de l'exécutif donc c'est la
constitution qui prévoit ce processus
que d'autre part il ya des observateurs
internationaux comme en 2018 qui vont
être présents le dimanche et que le lord
d'une hta précédent scrutin l'ancien
président carter la fondation jimmy
carter considéré que le processus
électoral vénézuélien était le plus l'un
des meilleurs au monde
et rappelons aussi que lol le système
électoral venezuela est fondé sur un
système de machine électorale de
machines à voter avec un bulletin
électronique et c'est un système
électoral relativement fiable écoutez je
vais
a priori ça n'a pas été avérée le
système électoral vénézuélien peut être
contesté par une petite partie de
l'opposition il frange de plus en plus
radicale
rappelons que roanne gouardo qui avait
d'abord été du président de l'assemblée
nationale n'est plus président depuis le
début de l'année puisque au fond il y
avait un système de rotation interne au
sein de l'opposition
donc il n'est plus président de
l'assemblée nationale vénézuélienne
il est simplement candidat autoproclamé
président du venezuela
mais là une partie de plus en plus
important de l'opposition se détache de
cette frange radicale qu'il ya de moins
en moins d'écho dans le pays et qui fait
campagne auprès d'eux je dirais des
grands réseaux internationaux de presse
et à l'étranger alors vous parliez des
observateurs internationaux qui seront
présents sur place mais pas l'union
européenne qui a décidé de repousser
l'invitation de l'état avait des yeux et
d'un est-ce qu'on doit y voir la main
des états unis quand sow alors l'union
européenne il ya une position il ya
certains pays de l'union européenne qui
ne sont pas sur cette ligne là le
l'union européenne c'est en grande
partie aligné sur la la diplomatie trump
en tout cas sur cette affaire et c'est
pour pour je pense probablement pour des
raisons de de stature et de position
l'union européenne ce que ce ne serait
pas se déjuger par rapport à une
validation peut être un peu rapide du
statut de droit noyau en tant que
président autoproclamé dans le sillage
de certains pays dont la france
l'espagne et quelques autres mais pas
tous les pays de l'union européenne
d'une part mais probablement l'union
européenne doit probablement prendre le
temps pour pouvoir revenir à une
reconnaissance des réalités de terrain
sur le plan électoral vénézuélien
rappelons aussi que pour prendre une
image
l'union européenne s'était un peu figé
par exemple dans une position vis-à-vis
de cuba
une disposition dite commune qui a duré
une quinzaine d'années et au bout de 15
ans l'union européenne a fini par
changer de cap et reconnaître que cette
stratégie n'avait pas produit de
résultats il y avait été une position
qui a été révisé et peut donc imaginer
aussi que d'autres pays du monde savait
que l'onu l'onu en tant que qui
représente le point de vue de la grande
majorité des pays dont le monde africain
asiatique et une grande partie pays
d'amérique latine ne reconnaissent pas
monsieur guido comme président
autoproclamé du venezuela
merci stéphane witkowski président du
conseil de gestion de l'institut des
hautes études de l'amérique latine
d'avoir été avec nous